okay so just to clarify you are
comparing women Muslim women wearing
burkas to not being able to go into a
bank where in a crash helmets all right
what I'm saying is that you're not
allowed to go into a bank with your face
covered so the CCT can't see you that's
it that's important that these that is
that what's that got to do with anything
well that's the rules of going into the
bank you have to show your face that got
to do with our suggesting that women in
a burqa look like bank robbers well with
this there's milk there's millions of
years of human evolution that we look
for affirmation for our own words and
actions in the faces of others and when
people can't see someone's face it makes
them feel uncomfortable so they don't
get that that behavioral feedback and it
makes me uncomfortable but know someone
wearing a burka doesn't with me any more
uncomfortable than trying to have a
conversation with someone wear a crash
helmet with the visor down that makes me
feel uncomfortable as well
that's just perfectly natural so you
feel uncomfortable having a conversation
with a woman who's wearing a burqa I
think I do because when I'm speaking to
someone and I want to see their reaction
to my actions and my words you look at
their face there's millions of years of
human evolution in judging people's
reactions from their faces and obviously
that without that feedback the
conversation is very difficult because
that's what we're used to
okay I'm just gonna have to ask you that
again you feel uncomfortable having a
conversation with a woman who is wearing
a burqa with it not not with anyone with
their face covered yes
I do if they were wearing a mask or if
they're wearing a crash helmet with the
visor down it's it's it's very difficult
to to get that empathy and that that
behavioral feedback of whether they
approve or disapprove of what I'm saying
or the way I'm saying it yes that's very
difficult